what can a modern woman do for a man to
outperform what traditional women have
offered in the past
or what can a modern woman so what can a
modern woman do for a man to outperform
the traditional women
that what traditional women have offered
in the past I would say I would say help
with his career because back back in the
day tradition like the women didn't have
the opportunities in the career space to
open doors or to provide like even even
simple things is just like
I remember I was dating a girl once we
went and trained to the gym together and
a guy because she was like attractive a
guy gave her like like a free foam thing
for training and she just gave it to me
and I was just like she used her perks
to serve my life in some way so I'll
probably say the difference is I forgot
if a woman can help a man in his career
in some way that's something that
traditional women traditionally couldn't
have done because they didn't have
access to that but I would always I
would also say instead of instead of
trying to outdo the traditional women I
would say bring back what traditional
women had their values right so be
beautiful be youthful be pure don't just
be sleeping around with everybody be
feminine be submissive and support your
man but I think the question is from the
point of view is like you can't undo you
know being gone through yeah you can't
go back and once you're old I think so
if you have been ran through yeah I
think really at that point all you can
do is turn turn another Leaf stop
sleeping around really all you've got to
do is
just take on the exact opposite
behaviors that got you to that stage
start being submissive which outside of
the sex submissiveness and femininity is
lost right hence hence the expression
toxic masculinity we wouldn't have that
expression if women didn't feel like
they need to be masculine and they don't
like the fact that men are right so be
feminine B submissive stop sleeping
around at that point and start
supporting Your Man start being start
being the
basically start exhibiting all of the
things the nurturing Behavior the
gentleness everything that would make a
woman a good mother that's what I would
say what do you what do you think Alex
um for me so I'm a modern man right so I
get a lot of a lot of the viewers are
people who are very traditional and they
really want that you know the old school
ways for me stuff like body count isn't
too big a deal it's more about how you
behave like I like women who are
respectful I feel like modern women are
very disrespectful they naturally don't
respect your time they don't respect
your attention
um and they just don't respect men you
know this toxic masculinity thing
um and so for me one key thing is being
respectful being feminine because I
don't care what anyone says feminine
femininity is a currency like there are
some days where you want a curvy you
know Pleasant woman next to you and none
of my boys
you know there's no amount of friends
you can have that would make that like
less gonna make up for it yeah and
finally I like women who Dynamic like
you gotta it's a modern world so the
whole idea of the provider and you know
the woman being submissive doesn't
really hold up because you know jobs
jobs you can't have a lifelong job
anymore salary is kind of can fluctuate
there's recessions and so I'm extremely
Dynamic I'm a contractor you know I
manage people
um and I may be doing other things and
you know starting businesses I've got
side hustles and I need a woman who
understands that and who's also a
dynamic like you can't be sitting here
kind of like waiting for the next day
like I want someone who's on their grind
who can add to my grind we can talk
about things because now women have the
same access to as mental education so
you can have as good a conversation as I
can baby you know what I I actually
agree with that right I agree with
everything you just said however I
believe they're very surface level I
still believe women need to bring back
and start to exhibit the the essentially
the traits the characteristics the
attributes that men biologically are
wired to right so that's not something I
have a question do you do you think
there's going back for modern women
because I I I just once a girl's been
damaged to a certain point like it just
seems like she's kind of like that
forever yeah I wouldn't say I wouldn't
say she can undo the damage but she's
essentially got to make the best out of
a bad situation she's got to try it to
some degree you can't undo that damage
I mean you can she can she can try she
can try also also there's a hundred
dollar Super Chat so I'm gonna read it
real quick are you guys go so you guys
know when you do 50 to 100 super chats I
just read them like as quick as I see
them no need to quarrel modern women the
hard lessons from men are learning will
make them adjust accordingly the
regression will be back to the
conservative mean that's that's
happening already yeah the happiest
people I knew in University were the
guys who couldn't be bothered today I
remember because I used to I used to be
an RA so I used to manage a thousand
students
um and that's why I learned a lot of
this stuff because people talk about the
stuff they think I'm manipulative no I
just know women in it I've actually been
out here like for like years in it
um and one of the guys he's like I think
he's like um an actuary and his friend
to the happiest human beings I've ever
met I walked in there just chilling
making lunch for each other they used to
go gym do all this stuff but I never
heard them disgust me when they weren't
dating anyone they didn't give a flying
[ __ ] he still hasn't purchased anything
happiest people the people I know who
sleep around men as well because
hypogamy does make a lot of men happy uh
you know they're constantly in that
drama phase they're constantly like yeah
I agree it's not it's not a happy place
which is why everyone should have a
roster
same thing
sorry isn't a roster the same thing
but as in Shallow relationships with
multiple people so you're just running
through them as I said I don't run
through people like like the rush they
are actually valid people I just don't
want to settle down so why would I build
a really intense relationship with one
person but see that's you I think and
there may be obviously a percentage of
men that do that and that's that's fine
but you also have other percentage of
men like if we broke it down to a pie
chart you have the men that are out here
just having sex for ego and just to be
validated you have the men that are
doing it because they don't want a
relationship but they want some company
and that's fine they're not really
trying to hurt anyone out here but
they're not trying to sit down cool then
you have the men that actually want to
get married have like an actual life
with a woman then you have the men that
are actually damaged because they've
been they've been women that are damaged
now they have damage and they don't end
up getting with anyone because they're
no they get the most from girls actually
the damage but you know what happens
with them the 34 Euros the 50 euros the
six-year-olds that stay single but have
to keep dating young girls because older
women
she don't want you no actually it's
easier to get older woman
I think no I'm saying he'll date younger
women because the old women at some
point an older woman should either
settle or she'll be like I can't be
bothered to put up with this there's two
types of women they'll say oh they won't
put up with what put up with someone who
for example is too stubborn doesn't care
about their feelings don't want to give
them attention well that's just because
she's shooting out of her league if like
that's the way the guy treats you she
doesn't like you you're just in that
toxic place after they've not
transitioned like that if it's high
value though
different types of women I'm just
talking about different types of men and
I'm saying that's fine because you're in
a different place but I'm saying if
we're looking at percentage of men in
general you have these different types
of men just like how you have these
different types of women like there's no
general for anyone let's be honest you
know why like those damaged men do the
best in the dirty Market yeah because
they know how to play the game because
they're gonna flip in between Alpha and
beta because it could have been like the
tough guy but they also have deep
emotional needs so they'll try and
connect with these women emotionally
they'll flip between they're not like
you though you're saying that you don't
connect with them on that level because
you understand you're emotional like say
boundaries to keep yourself away from
that because you don't want that but
some men they might be like oh yeah I
want this actually freak out it's the
same with women that's what I'm saying
like the pie chart is there if if a
woman's freaking out in the quoting
stage you're doing something wrong
you're going away because every single
woman I date generally if they're good
intelligent woman most women want a
long-term relationship if they're not
with you as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible